i've always felt and this is my position
and a minority position
and not a not an orthodox position
that salvation was an act of
understanding
you know that it's all very well to feed
the sick and bury the dead and all that
stuff but that ultimately somehow there
was
some kind of a heaven prepared for those
who could treat this world as
a conundrum a puzzle paradox
and figure it out and you know this is a
there's this is a persistent idea in
folklore worldwide you get it in
buddhism with the idea
of the doctrine of the paranarvana that
if a single
being could attain enlightenment
all sentient beings would be
instantaneously enlightened so somehow
we're all waiting for just
one of us to figure it out yes the one
monkey
another example of where this happens in
a on a folkloric rather than a
world religious level is in people's
encounters
with fairies and elves you know
if you should for some reason get
tangled up with fairies and elves
usually the only hope the only way out
is an act of brilliant intellectual
synthesis
what i mean by that is they pose riddles
and they want and they want you to pose
riddles well if you're just
i think then you're in bad shape you're
never going to leave the hill you're
going to sleep
beneath the hill for eons but if you can
riddle your way out it amuses them to
let you
go so it's sort of this this idea great
world religions uh
present their own textual outpouring
as a legitimate area in which to attain
enlightenment in other words one can
direct your one's understanding
toward understanding the properties the
verbs
the movement of the stars the way the
weather works
or a book doesn't matter what
the quran the talmud the bible the
manduki upanishad
the anutara yoga tantra it doesn't
matter
but somehow and and this is heuristics
this is the the idea that textual
analysis can can lead to some kind of
higher understanding
what is there more to say about that
somehow you know in given the
strong intuition that nature is
organized fractally
and that man is somehow the microcosmic
image of of deity then somehow
our cognition our thinking processes
must surely be the most godlike thing
that we do and so doing them is a kind
of
practice you know
maybe you know we've talked about this
in other
evenings you know that maybe finally
what you're left with is a fairly grim
conclusion but mathematics is the way
because it does contain this it is an
infinite ascending staircase of
ahas into higher and higher realms of
unspeakable
but very pleasing understanding um
the the strange thing about the
spiritual quest or the quest for
understanding
whether it's spiritual or not is that
how
endangered it is by answers as i said
by closure uh you ask a question
what is the world well 50 different
factions step forward with a revealed
answer that they're
they want to immediately sign you up for
so and this sort of goes back to the
tone of the first
evening you know the truth doesn't
require
your cooperation to exist
but illusion does illusion
is in the eyes of the perceiver and in
fact the perceiver
brings to the illusion it's it's
montos it's it's power to be a thing
truth isn't like that so i think it's uh
people say well it's not reverent to
beat on the tires and
honk the horn and want to drive it
around the block
i don't know that's just a funny form of
reference to
think i mean the mushrooms said to me
once when i
in some epiphany uh
found myself on my knees and said you
know
get up stand up don't don't
meet this on your knees meet it
like an equal you know what's the
percentage of
this lollygagging and
of course it has that kind of
personality i mean it exalts
from what i was going to say freedom but
cognitive clarity
the buddha image of all of this is
the buddha of discriminating wisdom
and manjushri is always not always but
in his peaceful form always portrayed
with a sword
and this sword is the sword of
discriminating wisdom it's used to
cut through the scrambled illusions and
delusions
of the weary world to reach to the
to the bodhi mind
if you're if you don't know where truth
is or if there is a bottom
to the sea you're swimming in and all
that
then i think that you feel an urgency
about these questions
they have to be answered you have to
know uh
i don't know how many paths there are
that bring you to
this place but certainly with
psychedelics you
fairly quickly that urgency leaves you
and you realize you now have the tools
in hand
to make the expedition you want to make
and now the question is to proceed
judiciously in an ordered fashion
actually making sense out of what
what you perceive the spiritual
enterprise changes drastically once you
have
tools powerful enough to take you
anywhere you want
so it's not about the search for power
you have the power and then what you
have to decide
what are you going to do with it where
you want to go with it
[Music]
you